attention commencer
attention je commence monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues au moment où s'ouvre
l'avant-dernière séance de cette session
qui fut particulièrement lourde est bien
rempli vous me permettrez conformément à
l' usage de vous présenter quelques
considérations rétrospective et pourquoi
pas prospectives la session d'automne
est essentiellement celle du budget elle
est d'ordinaire harassante
elle l'a été nous avons cependant la
satisfaction de constater en toute
objectivité que cette année non
seulement elle ne s'est pas aggravée ce
que d'après les précédents on aurait pu
craindre
il faut avant tout recherché dans une
collaboratrice puisqu'une secrétaire
c'est une collaboratrice directe bien
souvent pour le patron lui-même on lui
cherche surtout des qualités qui
permettent de le seconde et le cas
échéant dans la forme dans le fond dans
la pensée dans l'expression elle doit
assimiler son patron la pensée de son
patron à simuler l'impact de son
entreprise sur le
la région de telle sorte que chaque
lettre chaque document chaque personne
qu'elle reçoit au téléphone ou
directement ce soit elle qui représente
sa maison on a l'habitude de dire dans
le monde du patronat que la secrétaire
idéal est une perle
il faut qu'elle soit sinon joli tout en
moins de d'excellente présentation
agréable qu'elle sache recevoir qu'elle
sache parler
[Musique]